remember age of empires it's an rts game
originally released in 1997 and it was
an instant classic if you asked my
younger self i would have told you it's
the greatest game ever conceived it's
the goat shoot the board dude
i'm shoot
okay
i can't i'm gonna die
everyone remembers the lan parties at
their friend's house then no one attacks
before 20 minutes and the sheer panic
when you hear oh
the game is built for competition
[Laughter]
now what is surprising is the sheer size
of its esports scene especially for a
game that's more than 20 years old more
than 50 000 people tuned in for the
hitting cup 3 final and it deserved the
hype and now it's looking like it's seen
as only getting bigger